indigenous people are usually forgotten
so we usually have to do things like
this and create these spaces for
ourselves we got honed really quickly by
the First Nations community all over
like not just in the US but in Mexico
also in in Australia and even in Sweden
we had a lot of sami youth be like
really really into our music just having
that that tied to being indigenous right
within our shows we like to put up a
mirror on how indigenous people have
been used throughout media history and
how we've never had control of our
images and it's always been showing
through a colonial in now we're going to
be showing you these scenes that you've
seen a million times but now it's native
people showing you these scenes of
native people and now you're going to
look at it different it's confronting
these very racist images within popular
culture but in in a setting where it's a
dance party I've noticed a lot of people
saying that they haven't really heard
anything like this and they're hearing
this power music for the first time
which to me is pretty impressive you
know live your entire life in North
America not here the indigenous music of
the place but it's showing that
non-indigenous people are feeling the
same thing with this music that
indigenous people are too
you